I'm joined today by retired Seattle
police chief norm Stamper who spent 34
years in law enforcement and now
promotes common-sense solutions to
criminal justice policing and drug
policy issues as a representative of the
law enforcement Action Partnership it's
so great to speak to you norm I think
just to start with to begin with I'd
love to get your general sense of the
direction that Jeff sessions is taking
the Justice Department with regard to
the war on drugs and enforcement of drug
policy are you pleased with what you see
or are you concerned well I'm absolutely
not pleased I think what Jeff Sessions
and the entire confidence tration is
advocating and in fact acting upon is a
reversal of very hard-fought gains in
criminal justice system reform over the
last 10 15 years and when we look at for
example just to pick one issue to dig
into a little more specifically when we
look at establishing prison sentences
for drug crimes talk to us about in your
experience in Seattle what did you see
if anything in terms of the correlation
between harsher sentences for drug
crimes and preventing violent drug crime
you know I think that distinction is
critical sessions and others don't seem
to want to make that distinction but
it's very important to do so what I
observed in Seattle and my 28 years in
the San Diego Police Department before
that was that the drug war itself is
fundamentally flawed it is most
disastrous a social or public policy in
my experience in this country since
slavery I think what we're seeing is a
return to some draconian penalties that
will do nothing to enhance Public Safety
or neighborhood health it seems that if
we sort of divide drug crimes into
violent and nonviolent from what I've
read if you apply harsh sentences
to those who commit nonviolent drug
related crimes you actually risk by the
environment that you expose these
individuals to I don't know if
radicalizing is the right word but maybe
predisposing them to get involved in
more serious crime and then on the
violent drug crime part it doesn't
really appear that the harsh sentences
sort of serve as a deterrent so I'm just
not sure in what way we benefit from
harsh drug sentences you know I'll take
the latter part of that question first
okay I just don't think it's reasonable
for us to think that the heads of drug
cartels or major traffickers or hand to
hand dealers in neighborhoods and
communities are studying sentencing
patterns and in informing their choices
to engage in that illicit behavior what
they're doing is making massive amounts
of money and the product of an illicit
commerce basically is violence that's
inevitable so what we see really is the
fundamental flaw in that policy
producing the crime violence and other
unfortunate social conditions that we
see in our neighborhoods but you're
absolutely right one of the best ways to
educate in the ways of accelerating
advancing criminal behavior those
engaged in nonviolent offenses is to put
them in prison where they're going to
learn a ton about how to commit criminal
acts how to disable and disarm police
officers how I've seen this firsthand in
in San Diego as I visited prisons
throughout the state of California a few
years back and one of the things that
that I think is just vital for us to
understand is that the organizing
principle behind this country's drug war
is prohibition and we know from
literally centuries of experience that
prohibition doesn't work that it can't
work when Nixon famously proclaimed
drugs public enemy number one and
declared all-out war on them it was
really declaring war on his own people
and disproportionately young people poor
people
people of color the very people in
neighborhoods across this country who
have had the most difficult time of
their local police so he put domestic
peacekeepers on the front line of a drug
war and of course you don't fight a war
without enemies you don't fight a war
for that matter without propaganda the
last ten years or so we have become much
smarter about the drug war and we have
said that those who are engaged in
nonviolent offenses are are typically in
the in the midst of a public health
issue
and and certainly with the opioid crisis
of a public health crisis and with we
were to treat drug use drugs certainly
drug abuse as a medical problem the
medical problem that it is we'd save a
ton of money and we would make our
communities safer and and healthier yeah
I mean it seems like it at all levels so
many of the interventions that have been
attempted by under the umbrella of I
guess what we would call the war on
drugs have just failed to sort of impact
the right places or the right people
what one example I recently read this
book in our economics by Tom Wainwright
which is super interesting and it talks
about the cocaine trade and it points
out I don't remember the exact numbers
but I think in the United States the
street-level value of a kilo of cocaine
was roughly a hundred or 120 thousand
dollars I mean does that sound roughly
right to you yes it does look at things
we know that it fluctuates as a function
of supply and demand yeah so one of the
techniques that has been applied in
Colombia where coca leaf has grown is to
basically burn or destroy the coca leaf
plantations and the amount of coca leaf
that you need to end up with that
hundred thousand dollar kilo of refined
cocaine is like a couple hundred dollars
and what the book points out is that
even if you burn half of the supply of
coca leaf in Colombia effectively
doubling the source materials cost from
say two hundred to four hundred dollars
it basically has no impact at the street
level right I mean it's a hundred and
twenty
thousand dollar kilo or a hundred and
twenty thousand four hundred dollar kilo
and you're really affecting farmers in
Colombia who are not really the source
of the cocaine problem is that sort of
representative of how the war on drugs
has failed it sort of impacting the
wrong people it is and we need to bear
in mind you talk about Colombia the
Middle East is a hotbed of opium
production as well and you can be sure
that the farmers who are growing and
harvesting that crop are not being
compensated the Taliban is terrorists to
attack this country are in many cases
financing their terrorism through in
effect u.s. drug policy so if we were to
get smart we would legalize all drugs
however radical that may sound we would
text and regulate those drugs so you
cannot regulate illicit commerce but if
we were to create a model fundamentally
different from the one that has guided
us and misguided us for so many decades
we would in fact begin to see a major
reduction in public air street street
dealing we would see an increase in
property values and disadvantaged
communities we would see fewer families
fractured we would see enormous
improvements in our crime rates sessions
likes to talk about how crime has
skyrocketed in the last year or two that
corresponds directly with the opioid
crisis which began frankly in doctors
offices and medicine chests right and
his mouth spilled out onto the streets
and the problem that exists today exists
under current US drug policy drugs are
more readily available today at lower
prices and higher levels of potency then
at any time since Nixon declared that
war on drugs yeah it seems if you wanted
to go with the first approach which is
sort of try to impact some of the
individuals involved in the trade to
stick with the cocaine example you don't
go with the coca leaf growers and
you don't go with the street-level
dealers you go with sort of the maybe
the cartel or the place in the middle
where the most cost or is added to the
price of cocaine but you're actually
talking about what maybe makes the most
sense which is you just don't treat it
as a criminal issue whatsoever you treat
it as an issue of Public Health and
would you not I mean this is sort of
there's disagreement over this but is
your sense norm that when you do
legalize you don't remove all of the
power from cartels but you do remove a
lot of it you remove their profits if
you were to legalize across the board
all drugs you would almost overnight
eliminate that particular problem the
carnet cartels are populated by evil and
greedy people and I have no doubt that
they would funnel their activities and
their energy and their tactics into
other areas like human trafficking for
example or gun-running or some other
illicit form of Commerce but we could
dramatically improve the health of
America's cities if we were in fact to
remove that cartel influence from
essentially drug Commerce and to
regulate it tax it which then enables us
to control it and by the way in offering
an agenda of legalization the law
enforcement Action Partnership of which
I am a proud member and my own
experience over the last 50 years in and
out of law enforcement suggests that you
concentrate on the behavior if you've
got somebody in a neighborhood who is
furnishing to kids you pop that
individual you arrest that individual
and and you apply a rigorous method and
policies of prosecution charging
hopefully with conviction and you make
those people who engage in that behavior
pay a price we've been speaking with
retired Seattle police chief norm
Stamper norm thanks so much for talking
to us today it's my pleasure thanks for
having me